let's talk about how to improve your
thyroid through fixing your liver okay
and I'm talking about a fatty liver
there's a huge significant link between
hypothyroid conditions and a fatty liver
the higher the liver enzymes are the
worse the thyroid is and I'm talking
about thyroid stimulating hormone it's
going to be lowered now what is the
connection between these two organs well
if you don't know this eighty percent of
the conversion from t4 which is the
inactive thyroid hormone to t3 which is
the active thyroid hormone occurs
through your liver so the body needs the
liver to convert most of that hormone
20% is through the kidney so if there's
kidney damage that's also going to
inhibit the conversion so if you can
improve the liver just by a little bit
you're gonna create huge improvements in
the thyroid now the other thing about
hypothyroid conditions is that ninety
percent of time it's a Hashimoto's type
that's an autoimmune issue which is
different because there are antibodies
against the thyroid so you basically
have the immune system attacking the
thyroid and that keeps it inflamed and
that's another issue too because if the
thyroid is not working and you develop
Hashimoto's hypothyroidism just the fact
that you have hypothyroidism that can
even contribute to a fatty liver but in
the majority of the cases the the root
cause of a fatty liver is either
fructose or some high carb diet it is
not the fat that you're eating that's
causing the fatty liver like a lot of
people talk about it's the carbohydrates
that are converting some of the studies
that people quote on having a high fat
diet causes by the liver if you ever
read them they're on mice and they're
not actually just a high-fat diet
they're a high fat high carbohydrate
diet if you mix the two that's even
worse because that's going to exaggerate
things so this is what I'm going to
recommend okay to improve this situation
we're just going to improve the function
of the liver but there are certain
things that we can actually work on both
at the same time like selenium for
example
is a very powerful antioxidant it can
also detoxify mercury too so selenium is
not just good for the thyroid it's also
good for the liver if you have an
autoimmune case you're going to generate
a lot of hydrogen peroxide and this will
act as an antioxidant to kind of counter
the free radical damage that occurs from
your own immune system number two
healthy Kido in in a minute fasting
essential for removing fat from the
liver we're cutting the carbs down and
we're also doing in a minute fasting now
what's gonna happen is that if you have
a belly and you have fat around the
organs your body is going to go after
the fatty liver first so you may not see
it on your belly because you're gonna be
losing weight on the inside so once the
liver fat is gone and then you'll start
seeing reduction in your belly or at
least you'll see it a lot faster so this
is very very important milk thistle is
one of the best herbs for the liver to
help strengthen the function of the
liver cells choline is a type of B
vitamin that will act directly on the
liver and it will actually help dissolve
some of this fat and by the way guess
what food is high in choline egg yolks
interesting and number five zinc is not
just good for the thyroid but the liver
as well and vitamin D so vitamin D zinc
and selenium are really good for an
autoimmune situation but it's also good
for the liver so in summary follow this
list improve the liver to actually help
your thyroid and lastly check out these
other very interesting videos on the
thyroid that I have on this page